Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the brand new rollback format
of the Rich Roll podcast,
where we share the best episodes
from our audio-only catalog with all of you guys.
Currently, almost 300 incredible evergreen conversations are
nowhere to be found on YouTube.
And so to begin to remedy this misfortune,
we bring you my gravely-voiced brother from another mother.
The bon vivant at large known as Mishka Shubaly.
Mishka is a dear friend,
and has been on the podcast many, many times.
He's a writer and musician
who pens true stories about drink, drugs,
disasters, desire, deception, and their aftermath.
He's also the author of "The Long Run,"
which is a mini memoir detailing his transformation
from alcoholic drug abuser to sober ultra runner.
And it's also the work that brought us together initially
for our very first podcast,
which was one of my personal favorite episodes.
So let's roll around in the mud
with my brother Mishka Shubaly.
Enjoy.
I didn't know it was possible to live in New York City
and be that far away from a subway station.
(Mishka laughs)
As I'm lugging 50 pounds
of recording equipment with me from over here.
I didn't realize you were bringing
as my much stuff as you brought.
I would've-
There's probably a much easier way to do this.
Well, this is the problem, though,
when you run five Ironmans in under a week,
is that nobody's willing to come
and pick you up and give you a ride.
Where was my town car, man?
Pick me up in Manhattan to shuttle me out here to the-
I know.
I've actually spent,
we're here in Greenpoint, Brooklyn.
And on this visit to New York,
I've spent more time in Brooklyn
in the past couple days than I think I have combined
in the last several years of coming to New York,
or actually even when I lived here,
which I think is a testament to how New York is changing.
Yeah, the only people who haven't been priced
out of Manhattan at this point are the fashion people,
the Wall Streeters, and the coke dealers.
(Rich laughs)
'Cause cocaine is what keeps
those other industries running.
Of course.
But yeah, and in five years, I'll be in Philly,
because I won't be able to afford to live here.
Yeah, I was in DUMBO this morning,
and that is just, it's such a cool neighborhood,
but you can see what it's gonna be like in,
it's the next Tribeca.
It's gentrifying quickly over there.
Yeah, I used to train at a boxing gym down there.
And it was awesome, 'cause it was like "The Old Guard."
And I got to spar with a guy who fought Tyson.
And now, I'm sure that gym is there,
but it will have been transformed.
Or it's turned into a graphic design business
or something like that, a new startup.
It is cool down there and I thought,
oh, I'm in DUMBO, and I'm gonna go over and see Mishka.
I'll just jump a subway.
I had to actually,
the only way here was to go back into Manhattan
on the subway and then loop around.
And then walk 20 blocks.
You're remote dude.
I like to think
that this is the last dying breath of Greenpoint.
I have the sewage treatment plant behind me,
the cemetery on one side.
This is the last outpost of humanity.
It's authentic, though.
It's like a Polish neighborhood.
That was sort of what I was getting walking through.
Yeah, yeah.
Or whatever.
Yeah, it's pretty much a straight Polish hood.
And it looks like it's relatively unchanged
from probably what it looked like 20, 25 years ago.
Yeah, a lot of these people
have been here for a long, long time.
I've been here-
How long have you lived in this apartment?
It'll be seven years that I've lived here.
And that's the longest I've ever lived anywhere in my life.
And actually, I used to live here with,
I found the place on Craigslist,
and the guy I lived with was
this horrible blackout alcoholic, and-
Perfect.
Coming from me,
that I wasn't the worst drunk who lived here,
that was something else.
And I had like a folder of emails where I would be like,
"Hey man, throw up in the toilet, not in the bathtub."
And-
Little post-it note reminders.
Yeah, stuff like that.
And then finally it got to a point
where there was this smell
in the apartment that wouldn't go away.
So my roommate lived in the part
of the apartment that we're in right now,
and I actually, I broke in here one night,
'cause I was like, I gotta find out what this smell is.
Is this like a decomposing hooker?
So I broke in and he was morbidly obese,
and he had lost his job
and become addicted to online gambling.
And he had been hoarding jars of urine,
'cause he didn't wanna step away
from the computer and miss his hand.
So he would just piss in a bottle,
and there was like four of them here.
So I finally went to the landlord and I was like,
"Yo, you gotta do something about this guy."
That's heavy, that's dark.
That's some seriously dark stuff.
What happened to that guy?
I don't know, man.
I think that that was a,
actually I got a really nice email from him.
That was a bottom of sorts for him,
and getting kicked out of here.
And he found a new place and got a new job
and actually dropped some weight
and seemed to be doing much better.
That's good.
So I deserve a gold medal
for throwing him out, I guess.
Well, you did him a,
you were not co-dependent in that relationship, I guess.
So it's cool that, thanks, first of all,
thanks for having me over, man.
Yeah, man, I gotta say, it's a big honor.
The honor, I'm the one who's honored, man.
I've been watching your book
just consistently kick my ass on Amazon.
I was like, "Who is this guy?
What is this?"
It's a Kindle Single,
and it's consistently at the top of the list
in the running books and the category.
I'm not going to the Kindle Singles category
to see who's number one there,
but you transcended that and showed up in the rankings
for all the other books like way up there, man.
And I was like, wow,
somebody who wrote a Kindle Single is killing it on Amazon.
What's the story here?
And I was just ruminating on that.
I didn't know anything about you,
and that's when Dean, our mutual podcasting friend,
kind of introduced us over the email.
And I was like, oh, that's awesome.
I'd love to meet that guy.
I've been thinking about that guy.
(laughs) Yeah, I had a target on my back.
No, that competitive nature in sport,
going over into the Amazon rankings.
Well, you have to give me that victory then,
because that will be the only place where I'll be-
oh, you own it, you own it.
You were the number one Kindle Single for the long run,
atop Stephen King for how long?
How long were you sitting on the top of the roost there?
For a while.
More than I can believe.
Had I done it once for one day,
that would be more than I would've ever hoped for,
but it was-
Right, get the screen grab.
I do, I sent,
I did send a couple of those to my mom.
"Mom, forgive me, look, I did it."
But no, it's been an amazing ride.
And what's most ironic about it is
that I didn't wanna write that story.
And I resisted writing it.
My editor basically said, he was like,
"This is your next story.
This is what you're gonna write about.
And it's gonna be called 'The Long Run.'"
And I was like, "Dave," this is a guy,
this is David Blum, established writer.
He's been working as a writer
and editor in New York for a long time,
knows his game.
And of course I was like, "Dave,
you don't know what you're talking about."
No one wants to hear my drunkalog.
Yeah, exactly.
I was just like, "Nobody wants another whiny book
about how I totally screwed my life up.
And then just doing real hard work to get it back."
And I was wrong.
People love that stuff, man.
It's the hero's journey.
Yeah, and I think, too,
that America's really a place
where people come to reinvent themselves.
This is the nation of second chance.
This is like, we'll give you another shot.
Historically up till now, we love,
as much as we root for the underdog
to triumph like Rocky or something like that,
we also root for people who mess up and who make mistakes,
and then have to try and put it back together.
Well, because it's very human.
We're all flawed and we all make mistakes,
and I think people can emotionally identify with that.
I have to say, man,
one of the worst things about me is,
or two of the worst things,
two of the many bad things about me are
that I'm really dismissive
and I make really snap judgements.
And I knew your resume as an athlete
before I read any of your book.
And I was like, and I hate to say it,
but one of the downsides
of the sort of ultra competitive community is
that you run into a lot of ultra egos, too.
And one of the first things that leapt out at me
when I was reading your book was,
you said something about balance,
that thing that still eludes me.
And it's like, as a reader right there,
that's when I was with you.
'Cause I was like, oh,
this guy has gone out and done all these superhuman things.
And one of the first things
that he's gonna exposit us is that he still,
here's something that he still hasn't figured out.
No, it constantly eludes me.
And I think that's something that will,
I'll have to continue to work really,
really hard on for the rest of my life.
Being an alcoholic, being an addict,
being in recovery, and knowing myself and my tendencies,
and my attraction to extreme behavior, many of which,
many of those don't serve me.
And grappling with that,
and how to live in the world with that,
carrying that around is, it's not easy,
and I'm not perfect at it by any stretch of the imagination.
I'm usually very, very far from perfect.
Being a drunk
for a long time and watching people,
watching other people getting sober
and reading these sobriety narratives,
I just operated on the assumption
that once you stopped drinking,
and once you got past this sort of garish,
Hollywood dramatic DTs where you're sweating,
and there's like bugs crawling
through the walls and stuff like that,
that then your life is like sunshine and roses.
That's not the case, man.
It's not the case at all.
It's not like, oh, I'm sober now.
Life is perfect and great.
And look how grand everything is
and the sun shines everyday.
Certainly, I don't know if you had this,
but you do have the pink cloud,
and that lasts longer for some people than for others.
And I experience that.
But then life sort of intervenes again.
And you have problems that creep up
like everybody else does.
And in many ways, at least in my experience,
it's oftentimes more difficult to manage that,
because I'm like an emotional baby.
Because I medicated myself for so long
that when I finally got sober,
I had the emotional maturity of a 17-year-old,
when I started using and drinking.
I hadn't been able to develop tools
like a normal human being
for how to manage that kind of stuff.
And so I'm really sensitive.
I get really bent out of shape by small stuff.
And it can be very easily overwhelming for me.
Yeah, that's my experience with sobriety is
that sobriety is not the finish line.
It's the starting line.
Exactly.
Like you've gotten yourself far enough
to get to the point where you're in good enough shape
to do something that's incredibly hard.
And man, I know exactly what you're talking about,
'cause I meet people who'd tell me all the time,
they're like, "Why do you still live like you're 16?"
And I was like, "I still am 16."
I'm starting from scratch.
So at this point, you've been sober a couple years now,
three years, two and a half years or something like that?
Coming up on four years,
which I never thought that I would do that.
Which is huge, man, congratulations.
It's amazing.
And yet at the same time, you're still new.
You're still new and the nerve endings are,
there's probably a lot of nerve endings
that are still really kind of raw.
Yeah, one of the parts of finding ultra
that I really loved was the slack period
after you did the first Ultraman,
because you're like,
it's like I went out and did this ridiculous,
grueling race, and now what?
What's next?
What do you do after that?
And that's been my experience.
I started running,
I went out real hard and real strong
with just running on anger, really,
with no training and no idea of form,
or what the right shoes were to wear,
or what to eat, or any of that information.
And then went out and overran and injured myself,
and then had this awesome, massive year
where I just did race after race, after race.
And then I burnt out a little bit, and-
Well, you kind of proved
to yourself that you could do it,
so you crossed a couple finish lines.
And then you kind of get to that place where you're like,
well, what does this mean to me?
Why am I, what does it, why am I doing this?
What's driving this?
And what is important to me about this pursuit?
Yeah, and that was one of the things is
that for me, running was a tool, and it was just like,
I was gonna, if, for example,
if you're writing and you don't know
where the story is gonna go, and you go out for a run,
that's on your mind for the next four hours,
or however long you're running, you figure it out.
And I think that that's because it's on your mind,
but also when you're running,
you're able to engage a different part of your consciousness
and kind of tap into an,
you're unconscious on a certain level.
In some ways, you're turning your brain off
and you're kind of letting go,
and it becomes that active meditation state
that allows some of those creative pathways
to engage in a different way.
And I know when I'm struggling with something,
whether it's a creative problem
or just a life problem or an emotional problem.
Oftentimes, I find the solution on a run
in a way that I would've never been able to
if I was grinding at home trying to figure it out.
Do you remember those,
this is probably like late '90s.
There were like optical illusions
that they would print in the newspaper.
And what you had to do was look at it
and then unfocus your eyes.
And then you would see a 3D image.
Vaguely.
You mean like the lamp
and the two faces kind of thing, or-
No, it was more like,
I'll figure out exactly what it is,
but there's like an image there,
but you can't see it if you look
directly at it and if your eyes focus.
So you have to focus your eyes on an imaginary point
six inches in front of what you're looking at.
And then you'll see a wizard riding a dolphin
or something ridiculous like that.
And that's been my experience
with running is that when I go out,
I'm concentrating on sort of the discreet task of like,
okay, I've gotta keep my speed up,
or I've gotta not run too fast, or I've gotta,
so you're focusing on smaller things like that.
And then while you're focusing on that,
it's like, oh, I forgive my sister for that thing
that she did when I was in fifth grade or whatever.
You just get little gifts like that where it's like,
oh yeah, I just figured that out.
Oh, okay, cool.
It's almost like you're plugging from the loops.
I don't know about you, but I'll get into a rut,
and my mind just loops on some thought.
Whether it's a resentment or a conflict or whatever it is.
And I'll just walk around obsessing on some little thing.
And I can't unplug.
And I have to change my environment,
I have to change my behavior.
And I almost can't will myself to stop thinking about it.
I have to take an action that's going to shift that.
And for me, the easiest thing to do is to go work out.
That almost does it for me.
Yeah, well, this actually bring up
another question I wanna raise.
A friend of mine, Jacob, who I lost in 2001,
he was a pretty hardcore weightlifter and a heroin addict,
which two things don't really go together.
And I asked, I said, and I was a pretty hardcore drunk.
And I was like, "How can you bear to go to the gym?"
And he said,
"It's the one thing that I know that removes
that sort of nattering voice in your head,
better than drink or drugs is,
to just work out hard
to the point where you're so exhausted.
That voice is quieted,
and it's quiet in your head for a second.
There's no doubt about that.
And when I was drinking,
if I could somehow find my way to go for a run
or do some kind of physical activity,
that was fuel for my thinking that I didn't have a problem,
because it's like, as long as I,
if I can get to the gym even if for a half an hour
and I get through that, then I'm cool.
I don't have anything that I need to look at in the mirror.
Yeah, man, I know that logic too well.
I used to do the same thing with my drinking,
where I was like, well, all right, I'll quit for a week.
There, I quit for a week, I'm not an alcoholic.
Let's go get some whiskey.
Yeah, like I said to you
before we started recording that,
if I wasn't an alcoholic, I'd get drunk every night.
Only an alcoholic thinks that way.
And unless you're an alcoholic,
it's hard to relate to that mentality.
And I think it's something
that is just distinct to that kind of personality.
And you're the first person
I've had on the show who is in recovery.
And there's a lot of people have been like,
"When are you gonna talk about the addiction stuff?"
And I haven't really addressed it in audio format before.
So this is like new territory.
And I think it's important,
and I'm at peace with talking about it,
but it's also like, it's a vulnerable feeling.
And I wanted to know what it was like for you
when you were writing "The Long Run,"
which is a fantastic work, by the way.
You're a very gifted writer.
Thank you.
And I love the story,
and obviously I relate incredibly to your,
it's the inner demon and grappling
with the addiction that just,
I can tap into immediately.
But to sit down and go, all right,
I'm gonna pour a lot of this dark stuff
and inner demons and secrets
out on the paper for the world to see,
what was that emotionally like for you?
In two words, it sucked.
It was incredibly exhausting,
and it was scary, and I dreaded it.
There were a lot of times where I was like, ah,
I gotta just not write anymore, or I can't stop writing.
And often, I have both feelings at the same time.
And this is the thing though,
is that when I was writing that,
I really had to go back and confront a lot of things
that I'd put behind me or I felt that I'd put behind me,
and it's like saying, okay,
what are the two things I'm scared of the most?
I'm scared of the dark and I'm scared of snakes.
I'm gonna fill up, and I'm scared of drowning.
I'm gonna fill a pool with snakes,
turn out the lights, and jump into it.
And so that sucked,
but the end result of getting out of the pool alive
and turning the lights back on, I was like,
huh, even that didn't kill me.
And then it's cathartic, and it's-
Well, yeah, it's more than that.
There's a sense of, yeah, there's a sense of,
relief isn't the right word, but I guess freedom.
Because just the simple act of writing it down
on some level is making peace with it,
or at least acknowledging it.
Yeah, there's a lot of stuff in that story too
that I was really reluctant to put out there
because there were secrets.
It was stuff that I'd hidden
from my friends and my family,
and with good reason.
There's a lot of real dark,
and raunchy, and horrible stuff in there.
And most of it, sort of like deep, deep nihilism,
and it's weird and alarming at times
that that information is out there.
But man, the response that I've gotten
from people has just been so overwhelming.
It's been, I've gotten so many emails
and Facebook messages from people who are like,
"Oh, this is just like my journey,"
or "This was so meaningful to me."
And also, I've had a bunch of people who don't run,
who aren't athletic, who don't have substance abuse issues,
who have read it and said, "Man, this really spoke to me."
And-
It's weird, right?
Yeah.
And that makes me so happy that Dave pushed me to write it,
and that I had the Chutzpah to go through with it.
Well, they say in recovery
that you're only as sick as your secrets.
And when you hold onto those secrets
and you harbor them and they fester,
that you're only fertilizing them to grow larger.
And when you expose them to the light,
they perish, or they diminish.
And so having the courage to do that.
First of all, I applaud anyone
who's willing to be that vulnerable.
And I think that you're being authentic to who you are.
And it takes a lot of courage to say, "This is who I am."
And I'm staking my claim for that.
And you're gonna think whatever you're gonna think about it.
And for you to of be at peace with it enough
to share that with the world is,
it's a triumph for anybody to do that.
Well, thanks, man, thanks.
And I think that that's why
this Single has done well,
because it's authentic to who you are
as a person and people see that.
So even if they're not an athlete, they're not in recovery,
they're not an addict or whatever,
they can feel the authenticity,
and that's what they're connecting to.
Yeah, the way that I wrote it
when I was writing it was I just tried to imagine
that I was writing a long journal entry
that nobody else would see.
And to just be completely honest,
as if I was speaking to a priest or something like that.
And nobody would ever see it,
nobody would ever hear it, no problem.
So I just wrote with that in my mind.
And then before I could stop myself,
I sent it to my editor like that.
And he was like, "This is great.
I have a couple small changes and let's go."
And was like, "Wait."
That is,
I'm laughing because that's exactly what I did.
I would sit down and I'd start to write and I'd go,
the only way that I can get this out is
if I get in the mindset
that nobody in the world is gonna read this.
And I'm just writing it for myself.
It's a private journal entry.
But then every once in a while,
I'd flash to some image in my mind
of the book on a shelf at Barnes and Noble,
and I would just absolutely panic,
and be unable to write for a couple days.
And I still remember.
And I kind of overwrote everything,
'cause I just wanted to get it all out.
And then I'm like, now I have something to work with.
And the manuscript that I turned in was
like 150 pages longer
than the book ultimately ended up being.
And a lot of my drunkalog got cut down, a lot.
And it was much darker and gnarlier.
It got whitewashed a little bit by my editor.
And I think, in the best interest of the book,
and mine was a little bit different
'cause I was trying to balance
essentially three different stories.
It's the addiction story, the athletic story,
and then weaving a diet book in there at the same time.
I was like, "How am I gonna make this all work?"
And so a lot of stuff got trimmed.
And I had some pretty dark episodes
from the drinking days in there
that ultimately didn't make it in.
But I remember when I turned the manuscript into my editor,
I just looked at my wife and I was like,
"I hope this isn't the biggest mistake of my life."
It's terrifying to be that exposed.
Do I really wanna do this?
Is this really a good idea or not?
It's,
before I was getting ready to publish "The Long Run,"
I was speaking to a friend of mine, who's a writer,
and I said, "I have grave misgivings
about sending this out into the world,
'cause it sort of exposes me as just sick,
crappy human being.
And not in a glamorous way, just like scumbag.
And he looked at me and he was like,
"Mishka, honestly,
there's nothing you could publish now
that's gonna make you seem worse
than the stuff that you've already published."
And I was like, "Great."
So I guess, that is the thing though,
is that once you come out with these stories,
and you're like, "Oh yeah, I got really drunk.
And then I pissed the bed,"
then no one can embarrass you with it because you own it.
'Cause that's your story.
And you've told that story.
And the other thing is that inevitably,
if you tell that story,
somebody will come up to you later and say,
"Man, one time I pissed the bed too."
And that person may be a really hot woman,
Which actually, this leads me to my next question.
And this has been like my burning question I wanna ask.
Who's interviewing who here?
We'll pass the hat back and forth.
Does your wife Julie have a sister?
Because when I was reading your book,
I was like, "Man, this woman is
like the patience of Gandhi or something."
'Cause I know what drunks are like,
and I know what it's like to live with a drunk.
And not only that,
and to live with somebody in recovery,
to live with somebody
who's trying to get back on their feet,
and to live with somebody
who's training as much as you were,
and as hard as you were.
And she really stuck with you
through a radical transformation.
Yeah, she did.
First of all,
she's much more spiritually evolved than I am for sure.
And she walks her walk.
We met after I got sober,
so she didn't see me in the depths,
but a lot of those behavior patterns crop up.
And it becomes less about not drinking
and it becomes more about acting out
or behavior patterns that you see in alcoholics that are dry
or not actively engaged in whatever works for them
to keep them on the straight and narrow.
And yeah, she's been amazing.
And none of this, in all honesty,
none of this would've happened, Ultraman, the book,
everything that's come from it
all starts with her patience and belief in me, and sort of,
I guess what it is, initially,
she was like, "You should try this, you should do that."
She'd put books on my nightstand that I wouldn't read.
She would say, "You should be trying this,"
or "You need to change your diet, it's not looking good."
She'd always like, she'd call me out.
She's a strong person and she'd say,
"You look like a hell, dude, what are you doing?
And that wasn't working.
She fatigued of that pattern with me.
And she got to a place where she was like,
"All right, if I'm gonna stay married to this guy,
I'm gonna have to just love him the way he is
and let go of my desire or need for him to change.
Even if I can see through this mirage of who he is,
and I can see a better version of him,
and I can see how he can get there,
but he's not listening to me.
And I'm just banging my head against the wall.
And it was when she finally let go
and detach from that completely that I began to change.
And so there's this weird spiritual calculus
that took place in that.
And maybe on some unconscious level, I was registering like,
"Oh, wait, she's not pushing me anymore.
Now it's on me."
So it wouldn't be like I'm doing it for her.
I have to own this situation that I'm in.
I have to own my behavior patterns
and I have to wanna change for myself.
And honestly, you can't sustain
any kind of lifestyle change anyway
unless you inherently want it inside of you.
Yeah, that's the thing is you can't,
it's incredibly difficult to force someone to change.
And even if you force them to change, it's not gonna stick.
No, of course not,
'cause they're not doing it for the right reasons.
They're doing it to please somebody else rather than,
they're not internally driven to do it.
Like, "Oh, I don't want my wife to leave me,
so I'm gonna change."
Well, although I understand that,
and it's not a bad reason,
but the chances of that
being a sustainable change are not good.
You can't force someone to want to change.
And I think that she recognized that.
It's funny.
It's a very big, very gracious gesture
that you make by saying that none of this
would have happened without her.
But I think that it speaks to your strength as a writer,
because that's totally transparent in the book,
and you make it abundantly clear to readers
that this is a group effort.
That she really had your back at every step.
Yeah, and I acknowledge the support.
Left to my own devices,
I'm pissing the bed and eating Jack in the Box
and living like a Hobbit in 10-day-old underwear.
It's like, I'm not good on my own, and I don't trust myself.
What I'm meant to say is,
I have no idea what you're talking about, Rich.
I've never been like that.
I don't, yeah. (laughs)
But no, it's true.
And she actually wrote a blog post on that very subject
that was on mind, body, green that did really well,
kind of navigating relationships
and pitfalls in relationships.
And how she kind of approaches me when I'm difficult,
which is on a regular basis.
And her ability to just be nonplussed
by whatever I'm doing, and kind of like,
"Hey man, that's you.
Don't invade my space
with whatever nonsense that you're coming at me with,
whether it's negative energy or whatever it is."
And it takes a strong constitution for that.
Yeah, yeah.
And so I'm lucky.
I'm blessed in that regard.
And I realize not everybody is in a relationship like that,
and I don't take it for granted.
I, more than one friend has commented to me
that I'm an angry guy and that I get angry easily,
and that when I get angry, it's explosive.
And that's one of the things that,
that's one of the things about getting sober that's tough,
man, is because back in the day, when I got mad,
I'd have a drink and I'd feel better.
Or when I got sad, I'd have a drink and I'd feel better.
Or when I couldn't get to sleep,
I'd have a couple of drinks, then I could sleep.
And when I couldn't wake up,
I'd have a drink, and that would wake me up.
And then I got to the point where I was taking
all these different pills and stuff too.
Oh, I'm too stressed out, I'm gonna take a Xanax.
I need to do a line
in order to get through the show or whatever.
And then when you get sober, you're left with nothing.
Right, all your medicine is taken away.
You used all these substances
to manage your emotional being.
It worked for a while,
or obviously you wouldn't have done it as long as you did.
And then it stops working.
And then you're faced with this dilemma
and this letting go process.
And then you have that momentary elation of being sober,
and the great accomplishment that that is.
And then that wears off, and then you're like, "Now what?"
You're, like we said before,
a raw nerve without the tools
to deal with those emotions when they come up.
And I think that it gets into a little bit, for me,
and without breaking anonymity or whatever,
I work a certain program that works for me.
And I know that you have
a different approach to your sobriety.
But I know that if I'm not using the tools
that I learn and that I utilize in the rooms,
as they say, I'm in trouble.
Yeah, and listen, it's funny.
When you do something that people take attention to,
you often become the poster boy
for several different causes,
some of which you don't support,
or you're uneasy with the amount of support,
you're uneasy in the way you've been cast.
Yeah, I quit, I stopped drinking on my own.
After I had been quit for a little while,
I started going to talk therapy,
and that was helpful for a little while.
The counselor I was talking to wasn't incredibly helpful.
And then I switched and started talking
to another counselor and that was better,
but I didn't go through any peer network,
or I didn't go to any group or group therapy or anything.
And so a lot of people look to me
as the guy who's going to puncture
this horrible organization that is AA.
And that's not how I feel.
I have a lot of friends in the program,
and I think there's a lot of wisdom that's come out of it.
Me, who I am is sort of pigheaded guy that I am,
I gotta do it my way, man.
And that's the only way it was gonna work for me.
If I had to, if somebody, if I had to get sober in jail,
then it would've lasted until I got out.
And if I, especially if in the early days,
I had people telling me, you've gotta do it a certain way,
you've gotta do it a certain way, I would've just,
that would've driven me right back to it.
Yeah, and I'm not here to judge you in any respect.
You've stayed sober for four years
and you found a way that works for you.
And I have no opinion on that.
I just know for myself,
my way is usually not the right way.
And I tried my way for many years.
I didn't wanna come into AA.
I wanted to do it myself.
And I had my ideas about how I could solve the problem.
And none of those worked, and the hole just got deeper.
And it wasn't until I got to a place
where I was able to quash my ego and say,
well, maybe there's a better way,
or set aside my notion of what I thought was best.
And really, not try to will myself into the solution,
but to surrender and allow other people
to help me and to take direction
and to kind of have that humility,
which is not my default setting
by any stretch of the imagination,
was when I allowed this solution to take root.
And that's what worked.
That's what's worked for me and continues to work for me.
Yeah, it's funny,
what you said about having no judgment.
That's exactly the same way that I feel towards you.
Actually, no, it's deeper than that,
which is that I support you
no matter what way you're using to make your life better.
And that's the thing is that if someone gets sober
by doing jigsaw puzzles four hours a day,
and that's their thing, I'm for it, I support it.
Whatever process you need to feel better,
to live better, to have a more fulfilling life,
whatever works for you, I totally support.
And one of the most interesting stories
that I've run into after the publication
of "The Long Run" is my friend Gerard in Portland.
And I've met him a couple of times,
when I was like on tour and stuff like that.
Big boy, over 400 pounds.
I think he's lost 80 pounds to date,
which just blows my mind.
It makes me think that what I did of stopping drinking
and running a couple of 50 mile races is nothing.
Because when, and I think that's one of the things
that you and I are fortunate in, being primarily drunks,
is that you don't need alcohol from day to day to live.
But you need food.
Yeah, and food is, I look at,
I tend, because of my experience,
I tend to look at a lot of things
through the prism of addiction and recovery.
And the longer I walk this path,
the more I'm convinced that it transcends alcohol and drugs,
and it invades all of our behavior patterns,
and our relationship to television or food,
and foods that don't service, or exercise,
or gambling, or porn, or whatever it is,
whatever your vice is or your secret is or whatever.
I think that it's rampant.
And I think that it's like,
the analogy is like in the '70s,
when they called smoking a habit, and nobody,
the idea that nicotine was addicting was
not even part of the discourse.
And it's like, oh, I have this habit of watching reality TV,
or I have this habit of doing this or that.
And it's like, no, actually, you need to look at it like,
these things really are,
just because they're behaviors and not substances,
they have equal power over us.
And somebody who, I have a friend
who has been sober a long time.
He's been sober 21 years.
Amazing guy, former heroin addict.
And he's like,
I never thought that anything
would be harder than kicking heroin,
but I'm having such a hard time with food.
I just can't solve this problem.
And he's finally starting to really realize
how his relationship with food is addiction-based.
And breaking those patterns
because you do have to eat every day
can make your life really unmanageable,
and the health consequences are profound.
Yeah, it's ironic.
For the last couple of months,
I've been working with my buddy Jed Collins who works,
who lives downstairs, who's a, he's a comic artist.
So we're putting together a comic book
from a story that I wrote 10 years ago, 15 years ago?
And it basically follows,
there's one episode when I was a little kid
where I stole a big bag of chocolate chips.
And then my mom busted me with them downstairs,
just sort of like chocolate all over my face.
It was the summertime.
And I think I was like,
I think the only thing that I had
that had pockets was my winter coat,
so I put my winter coat on.
So I'm way too hot in my winter coat
with the chocolate chips in my pocket,
chocolate all over my hands
and my fingers and all over my face.
And she just had this response when she caught me,
she was like, "Oh no, what's coming?"
And I think she knew then that I was gonna wind up
to have big problems down the line.
These kind of issue.
And I still, I have a friend
who I just love to death who's in the program.
And he and I used to be drinking buddies.
And he actually taught me how to drink.
And to watch him eat is like,
it brings me right back
to when we would go out drinking together,
and just be like, bring me four Jack and Cokes.
And to see him stirring a big thing
of ice cream with a Snicker's bar
and putting honey on the ice cream and stirring.
That's an unhealthy relationship
with food right there.
And when you're an addict or an alcoholic
and you remove the substances, again,
it's like the behavior patterns are still there.
There's work that needs to be done to modify that.
When I was talking about that,
my mouth started watering.
'Cause I was like, oh shit, that sounds really good.
Yeah, it's powerful for sure.
And when you were talking about your anger issues,
what are the tools that you use to quell that, or manage it,
or what is your plan for overcoming that
or transcending this behavior pattern
that isn't serving you, or is causing you,
is disruptive in your life?
Rich, I'm starting to figure it out, man.
I'm starting to grow up.
I think I've grown up from 13 to maybe 15 now.
And I'm proud of myself for that.
A big thing is it's not unfamiliar for me anymore.
So now when something happens and I get angry,
it's like, oh, I'm ready for this.
It's the enemy I know versus the enemy I don't know.
And when I got really mad before,
I would just go out and run until I couldn't run anymore,
do pushups until I couldn't do pushups anymore.
And I think those are fine outlets,
because that's a great way to get motivated
for a workout, but-
Of course.
It's not always-
It's better
than picking up a drink or popping a pill.
But I think the,
and I think this is a part that the place
in our lives that we're both in now is
we're trying to narrow the aperture,
so you get alcohol out of your life, and that's a huge step.
And then it's breaking that food addiction,
that's another huge step.
And you just sort of like,
each day or each month or each year,
just get a little bit better.
Yeah, absolutely.
They say the road gets narrower, you know what I mean?
Because certain things
that used to not bother you in your behavior,
or I should speak for myself,
then suddenly they become bothersome to me.
You know what?
It's no longer acceptable to me that I do this,
whatever it is.
And then it's time to look at that pattern.
But it's also like squeezing a water balloon.
Once you feel like you've pushed down
and gotten a hold on one kind of thing,
then it pops out somewhere else.
And so there's no destination.
It's a life journey that will never be fully mastered
by any stretch of the imagination.
So it's just about what is the progress that you can make,
and where are the improvements?
Where do I need to be?
What do I need to be working on next
that is the next frontier.
Yeah, and it's like that annoying mantra
that your buddy kept throwing in your face.
That's why they call it a challenge.
It's hard, but it's hard because it's supposed to be hard.
If it was easy, it wouldn't be worthwhile.
And am I gonna be fighting this fight
for the rest of my life?
Yeah.
Am I up for it?
Hell yeah.
It's worth doing, man.
I really just went from,
I couldn't even hold down a job in a bar.
And the guys at the bars were
always so nice when they fired me,
or usually they were,
and it was just the shrug and the smile.
What he wants to do.
You know and I know what you're doing.
Yeah.
And it's that thing,
like, here's something I wanted to get,
I didn't mean to interrupt you.
Finish your thought.
I had one boss once who said,
"We just feel like you don't care."
I was like, bingo, yeah.
Yeah, you tend not to care
when you're drinking a lot,
but there's this thing that I got,
that I'm getting from you that I relate to a lot,
which is this idea of, on the one hand,
when you're out there and you're using,
there's that deep shame,
'cause you're harboring this secret,
and it's just, it's horrible.
You don't want anyone to know,
and you just feel like the lowest person on earth.
And yet at the same time simultaneously,
while you're letting that fester,
this idea that you're better than everyone else.
This superiority complex and in inferiority complex
operating at absolutely the same instant.
It's funny.
I called a really good friend out on that the other day.
And when I was driving home, I was like,
how was I able to recognize that in him?
And then I was like, oh yeah, 'cause that's what I do.
And yeah, I definitely had
that combination of arrogance and insecurity,
where I was like, I'm the worst thing ever.
I have no merit whatsoever.
But if I'm an drunk and I can still do the stuff that I do,
and you guys aren't drunk and you can't do it,
then you're more pathetic than I am.
And that's a horrible way to live.
It's a weird, false pride that I had as well.
And I think our stories are different in many ways,
but the important aspects of our story,
I think, are very common.
And that is that idea of, like, hey man, I can go out,
and I can do Jager shots all night and drink 25 beers,
and I'm still gonna be better
than you at this test in college,
or write better paper than you,
and get the A or whatever, get into Columbia,
all these sorts of things that, they keep you out there,
because you think that you can keep,
you can do this and you can do it better than anyone else.
And burning it at both, burning the candle at both ends.
Yeah, and academics are a great example of that,
because it's only in the last six months, maybe,
that I'm starting to realize that I'm gifted at writing.
And you are.
Now I'm figuring out
that it just comes easier to me
than it does to other people.
Because I watch some of my musician friends
who will just hear a song on the radio
and just pick up a guitar and figure it out,
or like they're playing it lefty,
they're playing it righty,
and they can just figure,
learn new instruments no problem.
And I had labor at playing guitar.
I've been playing for 30 years, and I'm the worst, and-
Yeah, but you're also, you're not the worst, dude.
Here, you're in these bands,
and you've played with all these people
and you've toured and you've got albums
and you've got apartment here
that's got like 7,000 guitars in it,
amp stacked floor to ceiling.
And I heard you say that on Dean's show too.
You're like, "I'm a terrible musician."
And that's kind of alcoholic thing to say, too,
because that's not an honest account
of who you are as a musician, I don't think.
Yeah.
And I don't think you believe that either,
or you wouldn't be trying to finish
this next album that you're trying to finish.
That's a tough question.
I keep coming back to music as something
that's incredibly meaningful in my life,
the same way that running is meaningful,
the same way that sobriety is meaningful is
that I can do it and do it and do it and do it
and never feel like I've beaten it.
I've found something bigger than me.
And that was a big thing when I was younger is just that,
even if I didn't win the fight,
I showed people that I could take a punch,
and that I could suffer really well.
I was good at those battles of attrition.
I would outlast other people.
And I-
But that's the power of the self-will,
this incredible self-will that you have,
that I think is germane to the alcoholic.
Yeah, it's funny,
being a real strong-headed guy,
I think that's what kept me drinking
for as long as I did in the face
of the mounting evidence that I was an alcoholic,
and that I had to stop.
When I finally stopped drinking,
people were like, "What happened?"
It must have been something really horrible.
And I was like,
"No, there wasn't really any one new, horrible thing.
It was just all the other stuff
that I'd ignored sort of finally sunk in,
that in no way was this a fulfilling life.
Right, you hear it all the time.
One day, you wake up and you're done.
It doesn't have to be some epic,
like a building doesn't have to fall on your head,
or you don't have to kill somebody in an auto accident.
You can just say I'm done.
Yeah, yeah.
And that's what happened for me.
I don't wanna say I've never craved a drink since then,
but it's like the spell was over,
and I could just see that I'd had every good night
on alcohol that I was gonna have,
and that the bad nights were just gonna repeat themselves.
Until I had one night that I wasn't gonna wake up from.
And I think it's a fallacy in recovery,
this idea that, now that you're sober,
you're not going to crave,
or there aren't gonna be moments
that are gonna be tricky to navigate.
The miracle is that an alcoholic isn't drunk all the time.
It's a miracle that you're not drinking.
And so I think it's important to acknowledge,
hey, I'm still an alcoholic.
I'm choosing not to drink today.
And some days are easier than others.
But this pressure to be this person
who holds themselves out to the world,
like I'm recovered and I don't think
about it anymore and all of that,
that's great, but that's not every day for me, for sure.
Yeah, I know
that my experience has been atypical,
and I know that there are people who struggle every day.
And man, my heart really goes out to them,
because for me, I think for me,
it's a lot more about sort of,
it's more about alcoholic behavior
than alcohol itself at this point.
I don't have to stop myself reaching for a glass
as much as I have to stop myself from having a thought,
or thinking in that way.
(coughs) One of my-
Thoughts and emotions are gonna happen though.
What's important is how you behave in reaction to those.
One of the things that I am really proud of is
that my mantra the last couple years
before I quit drinking was just fuck it.
Everybody's gotta die.
I've gotta die someday.
What day is it today, Monday?
Monday night, great night to go out, fuck it.
And now when I'm in traffic and somebody cuts me off,
or I knock one of the million guitars
that you see around the apartment,
I knock one of them over and it puts a dent
in the fingerboard or something like that.
I think, fuck it, it's not such a big deal.
And so I've been able to invert that.
But yeah, man, those thoughts still,
that's the thing is there is no firewall that's perfect.
And in fact, one of the things that I think
helped me in the long run
with quitting alcohol was working in a bar.
Because every night that I worked,
there was the entire alphabet
of alcohol there available for me free,
the alpha and the omega of alcohol.
So I knew that I wasn't avoiding temptation.
That it was sort of like,
'cause that's the thing is if you want a drink, man,
you'll find a drink, whether it's vanilla extract,
or rubbing alcohol, or mouthwash.
If you're determined to get a drink,
there's always one available.
So seeing it there,
seeing it all right there in front of me, that was,
it made it clear that the change had happened in me,
that it wasn't just a situational thing.
And then also, towards the end of my shift
working at the bar,
when you see people just behaving horribly,
I was like-
The romance is no longer.
Yeah, I was like, oh yeah, this is done.
This is totally over.
All right, I gotta go to the bathroom.
Hold on a second.
We gotta pause.
()
Please hang up and try again.
I feel much better for the break.
But no, I wanted to circle it back to,
you were kind of making this distinction
between your musical talent
and your writing talent and how music,
essentially what you were saying, correct me if I'm wrong,
is that music comes hard to you
and you have to really apply yourself,
and you know that there's sort of a glass ceiling
for you in terms of your innate talent,
but that with writing, you're finally accepting
that you do have a gift for this,
and that it comes easier for you.
And you're embracing that in a, I guess in a new way.
Yeah, I think that,
we talk a little bit about,
sort of going out and boozing it up
and still doing fine academically.
And when I was younger, it made me think-
By the way,
I'm gonna interrupt you just for a second.
So do you get shit for coming off arrogant
in your account of that?
Like, "Oh, I'm supposed to feel sorry for this guy?
He got into Columbia when he was a drunk."
Do you get like blowback?
(laughs) If I ever have
the good fortune to teach a writing class,
the first writing or the first reading assignment
will be for people to read
all my one star reviews on Amazon.
Right, I got a few myself, too.
I got some really, really nasty ones from people.
My favorite, I'm gonna, this is so great.
I read it to my kids the other day.
My favorite one star review on my book is,
"This book is fantastic if you're George Bush."
And it goes on to talk about how I had
this crazy privileged background
where my dad bailed me out of every pitfall
that I ever had my whole life and took care of it.
It's like the way that this guy projected
whatever baggage he was carrying onto my life.
And I'm like, when I told my story was like,
I can't get around the,
I grew up in a very nurturing household.
I had-
And you should never apologize.
And I'm not gonna apologize,
and I'm not going to,
for the sake of creating additional drama,
take poetic license with that,
and make it sound like something that it wasn't.
It just is what it is.
And some people will connect with that,
and other people won't, but I've taken flak for that.
Like, oh, you went to Stanford,
and I'm supposed to feel bad for you?
Yeah, the Columbia thing,
people make a big deal about it.
And I'm still $90,000 in debt from Columbia.
So if anybody's jealous of me,
I'm willing to trade places with you on that one.
Come on, man.
You're supposed to be here telling me
how you're hammering these huge Amazon checks every day
that come in the mail in a daily basis.
Dude, look around the apartment.
Where do you think it's going?
All right, but to get back.
So sort of embracing this talent that you have.
And by the way, I just retweeted today,
the article that you put up on,
the iReports on CNN about running a marathon
on Sunday to honor the Boston victims.
And I wanna talk about that in a little bit,
but that could have been a very bland post
that just said I'm gonna get out there.
It could have been a very straight up the middle.
But it's very clear.
And I don't know how much time you spent writing that,
but you read that and you're like,
oh, this is not like just an average blog post.
This is beautifully composed the way that you wrote that.
Well, thank you.
This is the thing, is that like,
I'm probably drunk from like 15 to 32,
so through most of my academic career.
And so a typical thing is I would go out
and get wasted and then spend an hour writing a paper
and turn it in thinking this is total garbage.
And then my professor would write something saying like,
this is a fantastic paper.
this really moved me, or new insights or whatever.
And would take that feedback and say,
oh, well, this is proof that the world is meaningless.
If I can crank this out
on a couple hours and impress people,
then it's proof that literature doesn't exist,
or that trying to communicate
through these little squiggles is meaningless.
Well, and what it is act in actuality is
just incredibly poor self-esteem.
That your talent still was able to transcend
that low self-esteem to be able
to deliver prose on that level.
Rich, the next nice thing you say about me,
I'm gonna give you a charley horse,
'cause I can't deal with it.
It's like, this is the thing, man.
That's your low self-esteem right there.
I know, this is the thing.
If you were just giving me
a series of direct personal attack,
I can handle that way better than I can handle you saying,
somebody whose work I admire
and whose accomplishments I'm envious of
to sit on my coach in my filthy apartment
and say nice things about me.
That's a specific hell right there.
I'm talking to the guy who's been on "The Moth."
You've done some amazing things, man.
Just own it.
I know, I can't yet.
I can't.
It's,
let me back it up.
All right.
So to get this great feedback
from my professors at esteemed academic institutions,
I would just think, oh, it's all bullshit.
When really now I'm getting to a point
where I can go back and say, no, I was gifted.
And and I am gifted,
and I have a gift to be able to write well,
and I seem to be grateful for it and appreciate it.
And it's a lot to learn, man.
Learning something like that, it's not,
the paradigm is not losing your virginity,
like you do it once and then it's done.
It's like making your bed.
I have to teach that thing to myself every day.
I forget it, and then I'm like,
oh yeah, I have a gift for writing,
it's great, I need to appreciate it.
I have some merit as a human being.
I need to remember that.
I'm probably not gonna end up electing the carts
at a grocery store or working as a squeegee man,
which is how I assumed my life would end.
And so do you feel
an added sense of responsibility to tend to that?
To tend
to my own sense of self-worth?
Well, because,
no, to kind of get to a place where you're in acceptance
of this talent that you have and say, okay,
well, this talent comes with responsibility.
It's my responsibility to pursue this seriously
and lean into it as opposed to deflect it.
Well, I think there's a third option.
My father was sort of, he's a very gifted physicist.
And he was sort of oppressed by his father as a child,
saying like, "You have this gift.
With that gift, you have this responsibility.
And you have to do this.
You have to take care of other people."
And I guess the way that I try to frame it is
that I have an awesome opportunity,
and I'm just waking up to it now, man,
that I can have this life where I go
and do crazy races with my friends and hang out,
and eat watermelon on the trail,
running the Finger Lakes 50s with some amazing runners.
And I get to hang out in my underwear all day
and basically write the equivalent
of a long, funny email to my mom,
and people will read it, and people will dig it.
And so I'm trying to just say,
trying to learn to go with the flow, man,
and say, oh, work to your strengths.
What do you think is,
I'm obsessed with creative people.
I'm obsessed with artists.
And there's definitely a jealousy aspect of that going on.
And I find that in recovery,
I just meet some of the most brilliant,
creative people that I've ever met.
And I'm interested in your thoughts on,
there's this nexus between the romanticization
of using drugs and alcohol,
and how that fosters creativity.
Or this sort of misidentification of that relationship,
and then getting sober and saying, "Oh my God,
I'm never gonna have another creative thought.
How am I gonna be an artist without this crutch
that I thought was stimulating all of my creativity?"
Yeah, as a musician and as a songwriter,
I certainly built all my writing around alcohol,
and around being a drunk,
and around drinking and failing.
Hold on, I'm gonna close the door.
All right, no problem.
So as a musician and as a songwriter,
I really built my sense of self around alcohol and failure,
which were like my two sidekicks.
And then now I find myself in a really bizarre situation
where I think I have an audience of people
who would be interested in my music.
And I really feel weird about playing my old stuff,
and I'm not writing a lot of new stuff.
So yeah, that's a corner that I've yet to turn.
What I hear all the time is
that there is that fear, and then ultimately,
with the foundation of sobriety,
these artists are able to become creative fonts
far in excess of anything
that they thought they would be prior.
And despite grappling with this idea
that I'm never gonna be able to create again
without my drug of choice.
Yeah, my writing has certainly exploded,
and I'm so grateful for that.
And actually, you know what?
This is really funny.
This is an interesting thing.
I sent out a book proposal recently, which,
there was all this hype going into it,
and I was like, oh, awesome, I'm gonna get a book deal.
Didn't happen.
Didn't get a single bit on the project.
And it was heartbreaking.
And I went to my kickboxing class and beat some people up.
And then I was driving back and I was like,
I'm still crazy about this.
What am I gonna do now?
Am I gonna go out and run until the sun comes up?
And then the whole next day will be shot?
Am I gonna go and take a drink?
No.
And I just came home, and I showered.
And then there was a song that my friend had sent me
that he wanted me to write lyrics and do vocals for,
that I've been putting off and putting off and putting off
because of this writing, because of the book proposal.
I finished the song and I recorded it.
And I didn't really think much of it until the next morning.
Then I was like, oh, okay.
I got this really negative information
that I'm not gonna sell a book proposal
I was counting on selling,
and I was able to convert that into another creative project
and harness that energy for creativity.
Right, and the bigger issue
at play really is having a healthy relationship
with things that you can control
and things that you can't.
So you have no control
over other people's reaction to your work,
whether it's a five-star review on Amazon or a one-star.
Or whether a big publishing house
wants to buy your book or not.
Those are things that are none of your business.
The only thing that you have control over is
the quality of the work
that you're putting down on paper and putting out there,
or putting on a CD with your music or an MP3.
So everything else is,
they say it in recovery all the time,
it's not your business.
And detaching from that is
where the hard work has to come in.
And I have friends that do the same thing all the time.
They become attached to a certain outcome
with respect to a project they're working on.
It doesn't go that way.
Or you're sitting around waiting.
Like you sent your proposal out.
How long did you wait before they're
getting back to you?
Oh God,
yeah, that's the worst thing.
And that's, you have no control.
Or you're an actor who's auditioned for a part,
and you're sitting around waiting,
knowing that if you get it, your life changes forever.
Yeah, and in those situations,
your mind just turns on you.
Your mind just starts to consume you.
And it's horrible.
Yeah, it's not a healthy head space,
so the only thing you can do is like, oh, I'll go create,
the only way you can exercise any control over whatsoever,
over your destiny, being a creative person
who makes a living off things that are coming out
of your brain is to just create something new.
Yeah, and I said this
to a standup comic friend last night,
which is to pursue a life
in which you have a creative profession is
to become a professional failure.
You're gonna fail more often-
Of course.
Than you're gonna succeed.
And you have to be okay with that.
The successes have to be meaningful enough
that it's gonna sustain you through the failure,
and that you can deal with it.
The analogy is, it's like making a baby.
Only one of those sperms needs to hit the egg.
Right, every other one of them fail.
Yeah, and you're good.
You just gotta land one.
Right, and truth be told, 15 years ago,
you sent a book proposal out, you don't get a deal,
that's it, dude, you're done.
But you're Mr. Number One Kindle Singles Guy.
You can own your distribution method.
You have an audience.
And so you don't need that gatekeeper
to give you the stamp of approval over your work.
You still have the ability to,
should you choose, to publish that.
And you know that there are people out there
that are interested in hearing what you have to say.
Well, and you phrased that in the right way.
A lot of it has to do with confidence
and self-esteem and stuff like that.
Do I believe enough in this material to put it out there?
And control and, or creative control,
and what's driving me, what's motivating me?
Why am I doing this?
Am I doing it to get that gold star from the gatekeeper?
Or am I doing it for my man Gerard in Portland,
who's hitting the gym every day, changing his diet to like,
I think he's gonna lose another 150 pounds.
I'm writing for him
more than I'm writing for anybody else, man.
I do, this is the thing is that I do have faith in editors.
I've had the good fortune to work with a couple of editors
who have totally transformed a piece of writing,
where at the end of the night, I hate them,
I hate myself, I hate writing,
I go to sleep, wake up in the morning,
look at the piece with fresh eyes, and it's like,
not only is this dramatically better
than it would've been had I been left to my own devices,
it also reads start to finish like it came from me.
And that I think is the sign of a good editor
who can make a writer more of what they are.
So this proposal went out
to 20 of the top editors in New York,
and if nobody bit on it,
I think that's a good indicator
that there's problems with it.
Does that mean that I'm gonna go back to them?
Who knows?
The publishing landscape is changing so much
that I have other options now.
You do.
It's not the end of the story.
And I think that's a healthy perspective though,
because you could be like, your anger could flare up.
"You don't know what you're talking about.
Don't you know who I am and all this kind of thing?"
And not be able to hear, well, 20 for 20,
maybe there is something here, and okay,
I'll objectively go through this again
and see where it's missing a beat
or where I can dial it in and turn it
into maybe something that has the mass appeal
that would interest that kind of house.
Or you can just say, no, I'm gonna be true to who I am,
and I believe in this,
and you can put it out and your audience will respond.
You hold the cards, they don't hold all the cards.
That's one of the, it's funny,
that's one of the things that I really learned
about getting sober, being sober,
continuing to be sober is that,
and perhaps this is just being a teenager for 20 years,
or this is sort of back to alcoholic behavior.
But I found that I was like a biplane.
I had two speeds, 100% and zero.
So if I like you, then I love you,
and we're gonna be best friends forever.
And if you annoy me, then I hate you,
and I'm gonna kill you.
So when I got critical feedback from these editors,
I was finally able to have a nuanced response and to say,
"I think some of what you're saying is true,
that I do think that the narrative may be hard
for people to follow at a certain point.
And if it was told from point A to point B,
it would be easier for readers to grasp.
But also, I think that you're missing something
where you see me as purely a digital phenomenon.
It's not a, my sales online have not been sales
of an app or a game or something.
I've been selling my writing.
People have been consuming it digitally.
Well, what I'm hearing is you're feeling
like the publishing houses are dismissive
of Kindle Singles sales,
or you're sort of this niche performer?
Yeah, that's-
Like, oh,
those little Kindle Single things over there,
that's not real writing or-
Exactly, that kind of thing.
The paper world and the digital world will never meet.
Well, that's about as,
for them to have that perspective is sowing
the seeds of their own destruction.
That's as myopic as it gets.
I totally agree.
And that's the same logic we saw
the music industry use 15 years ago.
And that's why a lot of those guys are now selling
collectible figurines on eBay
instead of working in the music industry.
The future is here, you know what I mean?
This is real, and get on, evolve or die.
Yeah, and I don't know if you're doing this or not,
but on your website, on your blog,
you should give people the ability
to subscribe to your site, and collect those emails,
and cultivate your audience
so that you can directly serve them with your writing.
And it doesn't have to be a million people.
It's just people that enjoy what you have to offer,
and that can grow organically,
and not in any kind of pitchy sales way,
just people who grow gravitate to what you have to offer,
and you become self-sustaining in that way.
Yeah, and that's what appeals
to me is not a white Mercedes-Benz, but just to,
I would be grateful for the opportunity to-
Why white?
That just seemed to me
like the most ridiculous thing ever.
With the bejeweled license plate holder on it?
Yeah, well, driving a nice car
in New York is just the height of stupidity anyway.
But if you live in LA,
you know how quickly a white car gets filthy.
There's a lot of white Mercedes.
But yeah, and that's not what I want, man.
I want sustainability, that was the thing.
Drinking was not sustainable.
I could not continue that.
And I just could not continue the level I was at.
And to take every drink that was offered to me,
or that was bought for me, would be my end.
And so with my writing now,
my goal is just to create something sustainable.
I wanna be able to support myself from my writing,
and I wanna always have an audience, and that's it.
And you have that,
and you can continue to have that.
Yeah, yeah.
All right,
we gotta shift gears a little bit,
because we're like an hour and a half in here,
we haven't even talked about running.
It's like, "I thought this was a health podcast.
What are you guys talking about?"`
I'm interested in, I've had a bunch of runners on the show,
and I think what I'm interested in with you is
this sort of unique relationship
between addiction, recovery, and running.
What is it inside of you,
or what do you think that it is that's common
with the kind of sober alcoholic
that seems to gravitate towards long distance running,
whether it's marathoning or ultra running?
Because you go to these ultra race,
there's tons of sober people.
Oh, yeah.
You know what I mean?
And they tend to have a lot of tattoos.
It's like there is an extreme nature to the personality
that it's like a moth to the flame.
Yeah, yeah.
So what do you,
how would you, what do you think that's about?
I have my ideas about that,
but I get the question all the time.
Like, oh, you've just transferred your addiction.
I was gonna bring that up, because I-
Let's talk about that a little.
Okay, yeah, I get slammed with that all the time.
I bet you get it far more than I do.
And this is the thing.
For me, taking a drink was always easy.
Piece of cake, the easiest thing in the world.
Even now, I have to goad myself
into getting my ass up off the couch
and getting out the door.
And it's still day in and day out,
it's hard for me to force myself to go
and kickbox with my buddies or to sign up for a big run,
and to do the training and stuff like that.
That points to me that this is not an addiction,
because I never had to goad myself into taking a drink, man.
But there is a reward system kind of embedded in,
like when you finish a long run,
or you get that runner's high,
or there's something about it that is alluring.
Yeah, there is a reward system.
This is the thing though is
that you can never get away from that reward system.
That's how we're biologically programmed.
We're programmed to feel pain or to feel fear
when we're cold, or when it's dark,
and we're in a dangerous situation and stuff like that.
And we're programmed to feel pleasure when we get sex,
when we get shelter, when we get food, when we get water,
when we get the things that we need to survive.
So we're never gonna be able
to escape that pleasure-pain thing.
And my counter to,
it's like I go nuts about the runner's high thing.
Because for me, the nomenclature is,
or the lexicon is important.
When I get high, I wake up in the street, man.
When I get high, I wake up at 7:00 p.m. the next day.
When I get high, horrible things happen.
My sister has two dogs, two stinky dogs.
Every time I see them, they slobber all over me.
I'm not even a human being to them,
I'm just a dog on two legs.
Her dog Karma, when I pat her on the head,
or when I scratch her ears, I feel pleasure.
That's not dog patters high, that's life.
That's just me hanging out with the dogs.
And yes, there is a chemical reaction that you get,
the release of endorphins and whatnot,
but I don't run to get high, man.
I run to live.
And it's a way for me of confronting my problems
and a way for me to confront something
that's difficult in my life.
Something that scares me.
The last 10 miles of whatever race you're doing,
you're just like, I hate this, I'm never running again.
You're really, you're just gutting it out.
And running for me is a way to embrace life,
and to say, yeah, I care.
Finally, I care.
I care about my life.
I care about my friends.
I care about my family.
I wanna be here.
That's beautifully put,
and that's put in a way that I hadn't heard it before,
Because I entertain the question a lot,
and I've heard other people answer the question.
And I usually say, and I believe this,
that it allows me to access a better version of myself,
for whatever reason, I don't know why.
I don't know why I'm attracted to it.
I don't know why I have a certain aptitude for it.
But I know that when I am engaged in it,
that I am a better person than when I'm not doing it.
Yeah, just not knowing you personally,
but just knowing you from reading your book,
what I see is self-actualization.
I think you went from unfulfilled potential
to extremely fulfilled potential,
to diverging on superhuman.
And I think we've seen a similar thing
with me from getting sober, starting to run,
and then watching my writing take off, man.
It's just been, the last couple years-
They're not disconnected.
Exactly.
And that's a thing is that writing, running, living sober,
all those things, they feed off each other,
and they play off of each other.
And if I'm addicted to running,
then I'm also addicted to being sober,
and that's an addiction I can live with.
Right, right, right, right.
The other thing is, Rich, not for nothing,
you and I are pretty intensely self-evaluating people.
We try to look at ourselves
with no filter and make hard evaluations.
A lot of the people who are telling me
that I'm addicted to running are like 40 pounds overweight,
or they got a beer in one hand and a cigarette
in the other while they're telling me
how I'm gonna destroy my knees.
And-
It's like the big,
ruddy face dude who's telling me
that I'm not getting enough protein
eating the way that I'm eating, looking like I'm good.
Dude, look in the mirror.
Yeah, and that's the thing.
There's a lot of people in this country
that would benefit from not getting enough protein
and not getting enough food,
not getting enough calories, being addicted to running.
This nation has an obesity problem.
There's no question about that.
If only more of us were addicted to running.
Yeah, I interviewed this guy the other day on the show,
Michael Arnstein, who's an incredible runner.
Oh yeah, I know him.
I've run with him
a couple times.
You run with him?
Guy is amazing, right?
And he is bouncing off the walls with energy.
And all he eats is fruit, raw fruit.
And he evangelize is this,
and he said when he's training really hard, super hard,
he's eating upwards of 30 pounds of fruit a day.
It's intense.
That's a lot of time on the can.
And I'm like, I can't have an opinion,
negative or positive on it, because I'm not him.
I haven't experienced what he's experienced.
I can't judge him and I can't judge something
that I don't have any direct experience with.
And he looks, he went from 242 to 228.
it's like he ran a 228 marathon eating fruit.
Who's gonna tell him that what he's doing is wrong?
He's been doing it for years.
He looks fantastic.
The proof is in the pudding,
you know what I mean?
This is the thing too is
that I feel the same way about ultra eating,
how you eat when you race
and how you eat to prepare for your race.
I feel the same way about that
that I feel about sobriety.
Whatever works, man.
If it works for you, Godspeed.
I know from my own,
sort of making a laboratory
out of races and stuff like that,
if I eat a handful of M&Ms
and stuff like that while I'm running,
I'll feel great for a minute,
and then I crash, and then I fall apart.
And if I eat bananas and potatoes and stuff like that,
foods that are easily digested,
but that don't have the insulin spike,
I don't feel as good right away,
but I feel a lot better at the end of the day.
Yeah, you're not gonna get a super high boost,
but you're gonna get
a more sustained energy infusion over time.
Yeah, also, I'll tell you,
I'm the protein guy.
That's, my mom always,
you gotta have protein with every meal.
That's what you need.
And-
She's the expert, right?
Yeah, hey, don't mess with mom.
And for the last couple of days,
I've been trying trying to do your powered thing.
Yeah, how's it going?
I feel pretty good, man.
You do?
All right, I was prepared for you
to tell me you feel horrible.
Well, dumping caffeine and sugar is a hell
that I wouldn't wish on my worst enemy.
And I'm starting to straighten out.
And I did have a couple of eggs the other day,
'cause I just felt beat up from the weekend.
And also, I think that's one of the things
that you make a great point about in your book is
you can narrow the aperture.
Just cut out Jack in the Box to start.
And then you can keep tuning it up
and improving it and stuff like that.
Yeah, I know for me,
I had to go all in immediately,
just like going to rehab or something like that.
That's what works for me,
but that's not what works for most people.
It might work for you though.
I was just gonna say, Rich,
come on, look who you're talking to you.
But I think-
You know
I'm the all in kind of guy.
Yeah, exactly.
But, well, and it's sort of like, okay,
you're off caffeine, you're off sugar, you're detoxing.
It's like, well, you know what a detox feels like.
You know how to weather a detox.
That's familiar territory.
Yeah, yeah, I was gonna, I was like-
So there's kind of like a comfort in that for you,
because you know that it will change and that it will,
and then you'll be able to come out the other side of that.
Yeah, for many years,
I was in the business of feeling bad.
(Rich laughs)
Something I do well.
Yeah, right,
so it's like, oh, I know what this is all about.
But I'm starting to see
the same thing that you've talked about
and that I've noticed a lot in my life
with alcohol and stuff,
just feeling bloated and feeling slow
and low energy and stuff like that.
And when I'm grazing throughout the day and eating a lot of,
just been eating a ton of fruits and vegetable,
my energy is much more consistent throughout the day.
It's a balanced energy.
Yeah.
I don't have to wait, write 40-
The food coma.
Yeah, I don't have to write 45 minutes
into my schedule to recover from breakfast.
Yeah, and that in and of itself is huge.
Yeah, for guys like us
to have a little more time in the day, it's massive.
And to get to your point
about closing the aperture.
I think that part of the problem, oftentimes,
if you suggest to somebody,
oh, try a vegan diet or plant-based diets or like, well,
they'll do it for a couple days or a week
or however long it is before where they slip and misstep.
And then they just say, "Well, that was way too hard.
I couldn't even make it a week, forget that,"
As opposed to, I would submit
that a healthier reaction to that would be like,
okay, well, I'm a human being.
Yeah, I've been eating that food X for 30 years.
It's no surprise that I suddenly craved it.
So let's just, all right, let's adjust,
and make the next right choice and move forward.
And the more that I just root it in the day,
like, don't worry about what you're gonna need tomorrow.
What are you eating right now?
Just focus on that.
Try to make a better choice about that.
It doesn't have to be perfect.
Progress, not perfection.
All these sort of recovery tools
that I think are so applicable
to how we develop our habits around food.
Yeah, no, it's totally true.
I remember being a kid and being like,
okay, I'm in ninth grade now,
nobody's gonna pick on me anymore.
I'm gonna do 50 pushups every day.
And I would do 50 pushups the first day.
And then I'd do 40 the second day.
And then the third day I wouldn't do any.
And then I'd be like, "Ah, I give up, I hate myself.
Why do I suck so much?"
And what you gotta do is instead of saying,
I'm gonna do 50 pushups every day,
say I'm gonna do 25 pushups five days a week,
and then I'm gonna start to ramp it up.
And then when you miss a day, get back on the horse, man.
All right, I screwed up.
Okay, back to it, back to it, back to it, back to it.
And that's the thing is if you just,
you only fail when you give up.
It's only when you get knocked down and you stay down,
that's when you lose.
You keep getting back up, you keep getting back up.
Well, and I think
it's about the stories we tell ourselves,
These narratives that we create and our minds
about things that are going on
that aren't necessarily the truth.
So it's like, all right, you messed up, you fell,
and then what's the narrative?
Oh, I'm a piece of shit.
I can't do this.
I'm terrible.
Everybody told me I wasn't gonna be able to do it.
And then you create
this self-fulfilling prophecy around that.
Whereas you actually have,
you have control over that narrative.
You can choose to create a new narrative around it,
which is, wow, that's so interesting that I did that.
Like, hmm, that's cool.
Well, I can file that away for next time.
And now I kind of know how that happened,
and I know how to avoid that.
Giddy up.
Yeah.
And the other thing too, is like,
I've been doing a lot of boxing and kickboxing lately.
And I've been punched once or twice.
But to get back in there and to go into spar with somebody,
and know that, oh man,
I'm probably gonna get punched in the face.
The last time I got punched in the face was
that bar fight where I fought those six dudes,
and that didn't end well.
So you go into it like sort of dreading it.
And then you get punched in the face and it's like,
oh, I'm still here.
All right, well, now,
now that I know that this thing
that terrified me so much didn't destroy me,
now we can get down a bit.
All right, now we're talking.
Just information, it's information.
Exactly.
I got a lot of information this weekend, man. (laughs)
All right, well,
let's talk about your run tomorrow.
So you threw this post up on CNN.
Let's talk about Boston a little bit.
My plan was I was gonna start talking about that,
'cause it feels weird to talk
about anything other than Boston right now.
Yeah, I can't believe we didn't start with that,
and I'm also glad that we didn't.
Well, 'cause once you get into it,
it's kind of hard to shift gears.
And then you feel weird for like,
okay, well, enough of that.
Let's talk about-
Yeah.
On Monday, I was just in shock, as I think we all were,
just really couldn't believe it.
I've been through a bunch of crap.
I went through a school shooting when I was 15 at my school.
Oh really?
Wow.
I was in New York for 9/11.
I got shipwrecked.
You know what I mean?
I'm no stranger to that stuff.
Some reason Boston really shook me, man-
I know I should,
this is the point where I should jump in and go,
"Wait, what, you were shipwrecked?"
But I already know the story.
and we've been going on for a long time-
I know, I know.
But if you wanna hear more
about Mishka's shipwreck story,
it's another Kindle Single.
Yeah, thank you for the plug.
And then-
Where were you on 9/11?
I was hungover, man.
I was asleep.
And my girlfriend's roommate woke me up,
and she was like, "Mishka, you gotta wake up.
"They just attacked the World Trade Center."
And I was like, what?
And I sort of walked outta bed
and watched on TV as the second tower fell.
And it was just like,
sort of like our jaws dropped then,
and we have yet to pick them back up,
just blew my mind.
And this is the thing though, man.
Post-9/11 New York, awesome place to be.
I remember being in the subway years after 9/11,
and this girl, I think iPods,
the new generation of iPods had just come out.
And this girl dropped her iPod
and it bounced on the platform
and then fell into the tracks.
She's like, "Oh man, I just got that."
And there was a train coming,
and her boyfriend was looking around,
and he looked at me and I was like,
I was like, "I'll pull you up."
And he jumped right in, grabbed the iPod,
threw the iPod, reached up to me,
I grabbed his hands, pulled him up,
the train came in, we got on the train.
And it was just like, we're in this together, man.
All of us, we're in this together.
There's something, we've got a problem here.
We got to fix it, I need your help.
I'm in, let's do it, done.
I never got their names.
They never got my name.
I hope they do the same.
But the thing that was
so heartbreaking about Boston is that,
and this is what I wrote about for CNN is
that it's like an inversion of Newtown.
And that was so horrifying to us
because here's someone who's attacking human beings
with infinite potential before them.
Those children could have grown up to be anyone.
We'll never know the contributions
that they could have made.
And Boston is the elites,
the best marathoners in the world there to compete.
And the globe is represented there.
It's not a Northeast thing, it's not an American thing,
it's not a North American thing.
Everybody's there, man.
And if you're, and as a Bostonian,
the marathon is, it's a pastime.
It is emblematic of the city.
Yeah, it's a huge cultural event.
And that's the thing, man.
No matter how gifted you are or what shape you're in,
you have to really try to run a marathon, any marathon.
And you have to really try to get into Boston,
to qualify for Boston.
So these are people who are ambitiously striving
to be the best that they can, to Excel at something,
to do something incredible, to live beyond the ordinary.
And to strike at that, it seemed to me as just,
that's terror right there.
We will not allow you to dream.
You will not be allowed to be ambitious.
You can't think about doing something incredible,
'cause we'll kill you.
And to which my response is, fuck you.
And I just, I got mad about, Tuesday, it made me cry.
And then finally yesterday, I got mad about it.
And I was like, no, this will not stand.
You wanna destroy this race?
And you wanna destroy it in an ironic manner
in which the projectile caused the people
who survived to have their legs amputated,
so they'll never run again?
Well, we're gonna respond to your irony with another irony,
which is that Boston this year will be bigger
and better and more memorable and more meaningful than ever,
because it's going to be like a pandemic.
It's just going to be runners who care about themselves,
and who care about other people,
and who care about competition,
and humanity, and ambition, and dreams.
We're gonna go out together,
and we're gonna go out alone
to show you that you didn't win, man,
and that you never will.
I think we gotta end there, man,
because you nailed it.
That was beautiful.
So mad about it, man.
I'm so angry about Boston.
I wish we could use the podcast to get people
who are gonna listen to come out and run with you.
But it's tomorrow.
I don't think I'm gonna get
the podcast up until tomorrow night.
Well, it's, I'm going out Saturday.
Saturday.
Oh, tomorrow's Friday.
Tomorrow's Friday.
I'll try to get this up Friday night,
and also, I'll tweet and post it.
This is the thing too, man.
If people wanna run with you,
how should they get in touch with you?
Write to me on Facebook, email me.
If you wanna get in touch with me, you'll find a way.
And I'll respond, and we'll meet up, and we'll run together.
And if everybody, and if tons of people wanna do it,
then awesome, then tons of us will do it.
And if nobody wants to do it, I'll do it on my own, man.
And it won't be any less meaningful for that.
Right, cool, man.
Well, if people do wanna find Mishka,
he's on Twitter at @mishkashubaly.
S-H-U-B-A-L-Y.
That's it.
And the website's MIshka Shubaly.
Yeah, the website is just Mishka Shubaly.
It's M-I-S-H-K-A S-H-U-B-A-L-Y.
And same on Facebook and all that kind of stuff.
Yes, I'm ubiquitous.
All right.
And you can pick up the long run and shipwreck,
and you have another Single up there, too.
What's the other one?
I have "Bachelor Number One,"
which is about my misadventures with reality TV.
And "Are You Lonesome Tonight?"
about a particularly committed stalker that I have.
Right, you're gonna have to come back on the show,
'cause I wanna hear more about that.
Is there anything else coming up?
Is your band plan-
I am working on my next Kindle Single,
which is-
Oh, you are?
Good.
Which is about being old
and still needing to rock.
Yeah, nice.
Have you you seen "Anvil! The Story of Anvil"?
The documentary?
Oh my God.
That talk about a triumph of,
the triumph, those guys should have given up,
and they didn't, and they succeeded.
And it's amazing.
That guy Lips, I don't think I've ever rooted
for anybody more in my life than I have for that guy.
It's an amazing-
He cares so much.
He's so positive.
Yeah, for the listeners out there,
there's documentary called "Anvil! The Story of Anvil."
And it's the story of a heavy metal band
that was poised for greatness very early on,
and made a few left hand turns
when they should have turned right
and ended up not making it.
And yet they held firm to their dream
and continued to rock it out and record albums every year
even though they had a tiny following in Toronto,
and it never made it big.
And even if you hate heavy metal,
have no interest in it whatsoever,
it's a beautiful story about the human spirit.
And what happens when you refuse to give up
and you hold true to your dream.
Yeah, I never thought
a heavy metal documentary would be so meaningful.
It's a sweet movie.
It is, yeah, cool.
All right, we gotta get out
before garage band explodes on something, right?
Thanks for coming, man.
That was awesome.
Rich, such a pleasure, man.
We went deep, dude.
Yeah.
You feel all right?
I feel a little beat up.
I may have to eat some eggs, bro.
I'm already-
You feel beat up?
Come on.
That was intense, dude.
You asked some tough questions.
Well, that's where the gold is.
You gotta dig for it a little bit, right?
Fair enough.
All right, man.
Thanks for being a good sport.
Thanks a lot for having me, man.
All right, peace.
(band music)